Joe Biden is finally acknowledging his
granddaughter
you know I've haranged him on this show
for a long time because I say it's the
the worst thing that I could say about
Joe Biden forget about all the
corruption in the scandals and taking
money from the ukrainians and the lies
and all the rest of it
the meanest thing that I've ever seen
him do
is not acknowledge his sweet little
four-year-old granddaughter
and intentionally not acknowledge her
omit her stalking from the White House
Christmas display
constantly say I only have six grand
grandchildren not seven
finally though
Biden acknowledges her
why is he acknowledging her
in a statement
to People magazine Biden says
our son Hunter and Navy's mother London
are working together to foster a
relationship that is in the best
interests of their daughter preserving
their privacy as much as possible going
forward first of all that's not true
Hunter refuses to even speak to this
daughter Hunter just went to court to
try to stop paying the mother child
support a hunter or to greatly reduce
the child support that he was paying
Hunter also just sued to stop the
daughter from having his last name in no
way there is zero evidence
that Hunter Biden is trying to establish
a relationship in the best interests of
the daughter Hunter is trying to
completely screw his daughter over and
and and mess her up and traumatize her
in every way possible that's all the
evidence that we have and Joe Biden's
complicit in that because it's not like
some private little spat between a a man
and his baby mama and a child born out
of wedlock and you say well it's private
life we're talking about the
granddaughter or the president of the
United States whether they want to or
not
this is a public matter that they have
to address the little girl is going to
know that her daddy that her granddaddy
rather is the president of the United
States and it's going to traumatize her
if her granddaddy is so ashamed of her
that he won't acknowledge her existence
and he's he's continued it that way for
four years now the girl's almost four
years old so anyway now he finally says
okay I'm going to acknowledge her good
on him good on him except he was only
bullied into it by a liberal columnist
at the New York Times Maureen Dowd wrote
this column that said the president's
cold shoulder and heart is counter to
every message he's sent for decades and
it's out of sync with the America he
wants to continue to lead very true so
he finally got bullied into it because
as we've seen in some other campaign
leagues this is becoming a big political
liability for him and so he dumps this
news on a Friday afternoon via written
statement I would not hold my breath
about him keeping up his promise he's a
dirty rotten liar that's been for his
old political career and he somehow made
a bad situation even worse in the
cynical way that he's tried to address a
basic aspect of being a decent human
being
classic Joe Biden we got to restore some
balance to our relationships you got to
restore some balance to Nature into your
body that's why you got to go check out
balance of nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day through balance of Nature's
Advanced cold vacuum process the
vitamins minerals and phytonutrients of
the fruits and vegetables are preserved
so that you can get that vital nutrition
in each capsule balance of nature is a
whole food supplement with no additives
fillers extracts synthetics pesticides
or added sugar pure fruits and veggies
are the only things they put in their
capsules balance of nature sent a bunch
of their products down to the studio for
our team to try
we all love them when you're disciplined
enough to take care of your health you
reap all kinds of benefits your body
will thank you for a limited time this
summer when you become a preferred
customer balance of nature they're
throwing in a free fruits and veggies
travel set and giving an additional 25
bucks off your first order go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles for a free travel set and 25
bucks off your first order as a
preferred customer that's
balanceofnature.com promo code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s the vague is a little
different from Trump and DeSantis in
that the vague is trying to cut a middle
ground between the new
more nationalist more populist
anti-corporate
Spirit of the GOP
obviously Vivek wrote a book called woke
Inc and his is regularly described as
the anti-woke businessman
so he's he's got that part going for him
but he's also trying to preserve some of
the classically liberal libertarian
Tendencies of the GOP in the last 10 to
30 years
so Vivek just came out and urged more
free trade and more legal migration
the cptpp I think we should re-enter it
I think this is a little bit different
than what you know the course of action
taken by Trump and exiting the TPP I
think that was actually maybe a decision
I think that I can use the leverage of
the fact that we did exit it to be able
to say all right here's what we need
done differently in a number of the
countries from Japan on down to be able
to say here's how we re-enter that on
fairer terms and so that's what I'd like
to see that puts us in then a strong
position from a trade perspective to
then take a look at where we stand
visible China so I I could go on for
hours on this one so we want to remain
really Merit focused we want to
obviously um I think try to attract the
people from around the world who are
also Merit focused and wish to join the
country and we should make it much
easier for them to join I agree with
that I actually fully agree with that
and that's one of the things where I
think the Republican party needs to
Define where we actually stand there is
an anti-legal immigration current that
you know which is which which I'm going
to be on the debate stage in a month and
this is going to be something that if
anybody has uh any any qualms with this
uh you know I think I'm gonna have a
real problem with that because
merit-based immigration is one of the
fixes to economic growth in this country
so he's right about that last part
uh Mass migration Mass legal migration
has been in service of keeping the
economy afloat because people aren't
having kids anymore and that's true not
just in America it's true throughout the
west but that's still a problem
it's a problem because if you just flood
your country with foreigners and you
don't assimilate them as we haven't been
able to do in 50 years then you're going
to lose the things that that distinguish
your country also because there's more
to a country than just keeping the GDP
up though of of course you don't want
the economy to collapse but this is
this is an issue that probably won't
come up on the debate stage because none
of the candidates
as far as I can tell support a reduction
in legal migration they also we want to
end illegal immigration but we we want
we want a lot of legal immigration Trump
trump himself who's the most
anti-immigrant major candidate in my
lifetime he said we want more legal
immigration than ever and this is a
problem
one because I think it it
not only threatens the national identity
and cultural coherence and the the
notion that we're actually a country
defined by borders with a real citizenry
that's distinct from foreigners but
two because the the majority of
Americans want to drastically reduce
immigration they don't usually say it in
those terms they won't say I'm
anti-legal immigrant if you just ask
them that question do you want more or
less legal immigration they'll often say
more or keep it the same but if you ask
them what do you think would be a good
number for migration
then you find out that and there was a
famous Harvard Harris poll that came out
a few years ago on this point you find
out that people want drastically lower
immigration like 60 percent lower legal
and illegal because very often people
will say Well about half a million
people a year and that's nowhere near
what we've got we've got we've got
double that just in terms of legal
immigration and then this year alone
we're going to have over three and a
half million
people apprehended crossing the border
illegally
who knows what the real number is so now
you're talking about a huge huge number
uh
no candidate is speaking to that right
now I think if a candidate did say look
we it's nothing against foreigners it's
nothing against people from all sorts of
cultures but our culture is collapsing
and we have very little that unifies us
anymore including even the same language
we don't even really speak the same
language anymore we need as we have done
in American history a number of times we
need to drastically reduce all
immigration in order to regain some
sense of coherence and cohesion for our
people and then in 50 or 60 years maybe
we can open it back up a little bit
again what does this mean for the race
it means that Vivek is trying to cut
more of that classically liberal
view while still maintaining populist
and nationalist cred uh the migration
issue won't hurt him because nobody is
talking about reducing legal immigration
unfortunately uh the free trade issue
might because Trump has now come out and
said
I'm running on mercantilism for the 21st
century I'm running on protective
tariffs not merely as an instrument to
get good free trade deals but is it good
in and of themselves Ron DeSantis has
been a little unclear on this we don't
quite know exactly where he stands on
this issue of trade and navavec is
saying no I'm I'm still a free Trader
and and
maybe it's a smart move for Vivek in
that it allows him to distinguish
himself from the other top candidates in
the field and now we have to start
talking about Vivek who everybody said
oh I came out of nowhere no one knows
who he is
he is now becoming a top candidate in
this field albeit in a field that is
dominated by one candidate over all of
the others but this is going to be a
test in 2024 how populist has the GOP
become how traditionally conservative
has the GOP become don't forget the GP
was founded on protective tariffs
conservatives traditionally have been
the pro tariff Pro protectionism group
of people in politics and the Liberals
have been the the free Traders so that
shifted a little bit at the end of the
20th century this is going to be a test
how conservative is this conservative
swinging of the pendulum really going to
be boy what a great clip that was now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time